hello I am them girl any love talking
about tech this video is for those of
you who are new to them if you intend to
program in your career one of the best
text editors to use as them it is
efficient because you no longer need the
mouse to move your cursor it's
ubiquitous because it can be found on
virtually all UNIX systems and it's very
helpful because it pushes programmers to
think twice before coding I'll be going
over some of the commands I use
frequently about how to insert navigate
search edit and exit in vim so that by
the end of this video you'll be ready to
edit your code there are quite a few
commands I'll be going over so if it
gets overwhelming don't worry I have it
all written down for you just sit back
and enjoy the show now let's try to open
my file called index is before I can
start typing I have to go into insert
mode you know I can't just unconsciously
knock code out like an atom or sublime
there are several ways of going into
insert mode the most common is lowercase
I it allows me to start typing before my
cursor to get out of the insert mode I
simply press escape if I want to type
after my cursor I use a to type at the
beginning of the line I use capital I
and capital a will let me start typing
at the end of the line lowercase o will
let me type in a new line after my
cursor and capital o in a new line
before my cursor now that we know how to
go into insert mode let's talk about the
different ways you can navigate through
the spot Jiji brings my cursor to the
beginning of the file to get to the end
of the file I'll use cap
gee if I want to move my cursor to the
end of this line I'll use the dollar
sign and to get to the beginning of the
same line I'll use 0 an opening curly
bracket will take us to the next space
of a paragraph in an upward Direction
like so and a closing curly bracket will
do the same but in a downward direction
now if I want to move right words within
this line W will take me to the next
word lowercase W that is and capital W
will take me to the next word separated
by a space now if I want to move left
words lowercase B will take my cursor to
the last word and capital B will take my
cursor to the last word separated by a
space okay now let's try searching
through our file lowercase F finds the
closest character of your choice to the
right of the cursor so say I'm looking
for lowercase a F a and I found a
capital F does the same thing except
that it looks to the left so let's look
for again capital F a and there it is to
find my name in this file I can use
forward slash the girl and there's a few
results that are found so to move
through each of them in the right words
direction I can use lowercase n if I
want to move left words I can use
capital n so you can make the forward
slash much more efficient if your cursor
is
on a word like so that you want to look
for throughout the file you can use
pound then thumb them clicking the pound
again will allow you to navigate left
words through each matched word like so
the Asterix sign does the exact same
thing except this time clicking it again
will allow you to navigate right words
so let's press extract and it's
navigating right words okay now let's
start editing lowercase D deletes
something that something can be one of
our navigation or search commands for
example D and closing curly bracket will
delete the entire paragraph over here D
wasn't awesome
and it's gone if you mess up on writing
a function and want to delete everything
up until and including this ending
parenthesis you can use D F and closing
parenthesis and it's gone if you wanted
to keep that last parenthesis then you
can use D T closing parenthesis like so
and that closing parenthesis is still
there all right
so DW lets you delete one word if you
want to delete five words or let's do
two for now we can do two DW and you get
the point to delete this entire line I
can use D D to paste that line that I
just deleted after my cursor I'll use
lowercase P and there it is if I wanted
to taste it before my cursor I can use
capital P and there it is I can also
delete within specific characters using
di if I wanted to delete whatever is in
it
I can use di t so let's try the leading
what's in this table using deit and it's
gone okay similarly D I opening
parenthesis will delete everything that
is in a parenthesis so let's move on
over took this parenthesis di and there
it is say I don't want the tag that's
over here what I can do is delete the
entire tag by using da2 and T and it's
all gone
alright so if you want just to type
after deleting a seat I is like di on
steroids it deletes and puts you
straight into insert mode for example
I'm going to delete whatever is inside
this single quote so I'm gonna use CI
single quote and now I deleted it and I
can I'm automatically on enter mode okay
similarly C I T will do the same that
the closest tag to I T I've not only
deleted what is inside I can also type
because I'm automatically and insert
okay I am done with this file to save
and exit you can use lower case X you're
gonna have to do Co semicolon and then
lower case X and enter but I actually
need the original code for this I'm
going to exit without saving using
semicolon lowercase U and
explanation mark that ends my intro to
them now you know how to insert navigate
search and edit in vim I encourage you
to get rid of your sublime or atom and
force yourself to use only them if
you're really serious about switching to
this awesome text editor until next time